- Welcome back.
I hope everyone
had a good lunch.
And we are ready to
continue with our program.
I'd like to invite Vincent
Brown to the podium,
and he will introduce our
wonderful poet for the day.
Vincent Brown is a Professor
of African American studies
and of History at
Harvard University.
He's also the Director
of the History Design
Studio at Harvard.
And he writes and teaches
on the African diaspora.
Vincent.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you, Evelyn, for that,
and thanks too to the President
Faust and to Dean Cohen and
everyone at Radcliffe who
helped make this
possible, this very timely
and I think important symposium.
Thanks too for inviting me to
introduce the brilliant poet
Natasha Trethewey
this afternoon.
We've been gathered to consider
how we live with the past
so that we can better
envision our future.
We cannot undo
what has been done.
We must remember it all, putting
our recollections together
in ways that allow us
to live our values,
and to enact them
for common benefit.
Now, I'm not a poet, and nor
am I particularly poetic,
but as a historian, I'm humbled
by the way Natasha Trethewey
engages so deeply with history.
And I'm intrigued by the
differences in the ways poets
and historians
work with the past.
Historians tend to follow
chronological genre rules.
We like time lines then move
our stories and arguments
along direct pathways.
We hold on to the
arrow of time, pulled
along its fateful
trajectory toward what
we hope is the truth.
Who owned slaves?
What work did they do?
How much profit did they
yield for their exploiters?
How did legacies of
privilege and loss
accumulate between then and now?
Now, Professor
Trethewey would probably
be too polite to say
it, but in some ways,
the chronological vectors
employed by historians
run parallel to the
typological classifications
of racial thinking.
We mark clear distinctions
where there are only overlaps,
intersections, and blurs.
A thing happened in this
place on this day in this year
and we can tell
you how it changed
into that thing on
another day years later.
But of course, this
isn't generally
the way people
experience the past,
any more than it is
the way they experience
belonging and connection.
Instead, most people look
backward, leap forward,
or enter fugue states where
we can be every win at once.
I am a slave.
I suffer those lacerations.
I endure the humiliations.
I continue to service a debt
for credit I never received.
This kind of experience
isn't easily represented
within chronology.
Temporal life makes a more
aesthetic and poetic claim
to the truth.
So rather than showing
how to write history,
poets teach us how
to live with history.
And in this, Natasha Trethewey
is a marvelous guide.
She leads us into
history as participants,
drawing us close to the
past, its aspirations,
predicaments, and struggles.
Alongside her, perhaps we
can see that better future.
Her work certainly
shows it to me.
So please join me in
welcoming the former 19th Poet
Laureate of the United States
of America, and former Radcliffe
Fellow, Emory University's
Robert W. Woodruff Professor
of English and Creative
Writing and soon
to be professor at
Northwestern University,
because she says she likes
the cold, Natasha Trethewey.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you.
Good afternoon.
I am honored and delighted to
be at this wonderful conference.
I'm going to read
a poem very much
about historical memory and
historical erasure, what
gets told, recorded,
passed down, who
does the telling, and
recording, and what's
left out of our national memory
about slavery, the Civil War,
and the aftermath in
which we are now living.
This is the imagined journal
of a former slave who
has enlisted in the Union Army.
The first regiments of the
Louisiana Native Guards
were mustered into service
in September, October,
and November of 1862,
and the second and third,
made up of men who had been
slaves only a few months
before enlisting.
During the war, the
Fort at Ship Island,
Mississippi called
Fort Massachusetts,
right across from my hometown,
Gulfport, Mississippi,
they served as guards
to Confederate soldiers,
military convicts,
and prisoners of war.
One of the men on the island,
an Officer, Francis Dumas,
the son of a white Creole
father and a mulatto mother who
had inherited slaves
when his father died.
And although Louisiana
law prohibited him
from manumitting those
slaves, after the preliminary
Emancipation Proclamation,
he freed his slaves
and encourage those men of
age to join the native guards.
The poem begins with an epigraph
from Frederick Douglass that
reads, "If this war
is to be forgotten,
I ask in the name of
all things sacred.
What shall men remember?"
Native Guard, November, 1862.
Truth be told, I do
not want to forget
anything of my former life, the
landscape's song of bondage,
dirge in the river's throat,
where it churns into the Gulf,
wind in trees choked with vines.
I thought to carry with me
want of freedom, though I
had been freed, remembrance,
not constant recollection.
Yes, I was born a
slave at harvest time
in the Parish of Ascension.
I've reached 33 with history
of one younger inscribed
upon my back.
I now use ink to keep record,
a closed book, not the lure
of memory, flawed,
changeful, that
dulls the lash for the master,
sharpens it for the slave.
December, 1862.
For the slave, having a master
sharpens the bend into work,
the way the sergeant moves
us now to perfect battalion
drill dress parade.
Still, we're called supply
units, not infantry.
And so we dig trenches,
haul burdens for the army,
no less heavy than before.
I heard the colonel
call it, nigger work.
Half rations make our
work familiar still.
We take those things we
need from the Confederates
abandoned homes, salt,
sugar, even this journal,
near-full was someone else's
words, overlapped now,
cross-hatched beneath mine,
on every page, his story
intersecting with my own.
January, 1863.
Oh, how history
intersects my own birth
upon a ship called
The Northern Star.
And I'm delivered into a new
life, Fort Massachusetts,
a great irony, both path
and destination of freedom,
I had not dared to travel.
Here now, I walk ankle deep
in sand, fly-bitten, nearly
smothered by heat, and yet
I can look out upon the Gulf
and see the surf
breaking, tossing
the ships, the great gunboats
bobbing on the water.
And are we not the same, slaves
in the hands of the master,
destiny?
Night sky red with the
promise of fortune,
dawn, pink as new flesh,
healing, unfettered.
January, 1863.
Today, dawn red as warning,
unfettered supplies stacked
on the beach at our
landing, washed away
in the storm that rose too
fast, caught us unprepared.
Later, as we worked, I
joined in the low singing
someone raised to pace
us, and felt a bond
in labor I had not known.
It was then a dark
man removed his shirt,
revealed the scars
crosshatched like the lines
in this journal on his back.
It was he who remarked
at how the ropes cracked
like whips on the
sand, made us take
note of the wild dance of
the tent loosed by wind.
We watched and learned.
Like any shrewd
master, we know now
to tie down what we will keep.
February, 1863.
We know it is our
duty now to keep
white men as prisoners, rebel
soldiers, would-be masters.
We're all bondsmen
here, each to the other.
Freedom has gotten
them captivity,
for us a conscription
we have chosen,
jailers to those who still
would have us slaves.
They are cautious,
dreading the sight of us.
Some neither read nor
write, are laid too low
and have few words to send,
but those, I give them.
Still they are wary of a Negro
writing, taking down letters.
X binds them to the
page, a mute symbol
like the cross on a grave.
I suspect they fear I'll listen,
put something else down in ink.
March, 1863.
I listen, put down
in ink what I know
they labor to say between
silences too big for words,
worry for beloveds.
My dearest, how are
you getting along?
What has become of their
small plots of land?
Did you harvest
enough food to put by?
They long for the
comfort of former lives.
I see you as you
were, waving goodbye.
Some send photographs,
a likeness in case
the body can't return.
Others dictate harsh
facts of this war.
The hot air carries
the stench of limbs,
rotten in the bone pit,
flies swarm, a black cloud.
We hunger, grow weak.
When men die we eat
their share of hard tack.
April, 1863.
When men die, we eat
their share of hard tack,
trying not to recall their
hollow sockets, the worms
stench of their cheeks.
Today, we buried
the last of our dead
from Pascagoula,
and those who died
retreating to our ship, white
sailors in blue firing upon us
as if we were the enemy.
I thought the fighting over,
then watched a man fall
beside me, knees first
as in prayer, then
another, his arms outstretched
as if born upon the cross.
Smoke that rose from each
gun seemed a soul departing.
The colonel said, an
unfortunate incident.
Said, their names shall
deck the page of history.
June, 1863.
Some names shall deck
the page of history
as it is written on stone.
Some will not.
Yesterday, word came of colored
troops dead on the battlefield
at Port Hudson, how General
Banks was heard to say,
I have no dead there,
and left them unclaimed.
Last night, I dreamt
their eyes still open,
dim, clouded as the eyes of
fish washed ashore, yet fixed,
staring back at me.
Still, more come today, eager
to enlist, their bodies,
haggard faces, gaunt limbs,
bring news of the mainland.
Starved, they suffer
like are prisoners.
Dying, they plead for what
we do not have to give.
Death makes equals of
us all, a fair master.
August, 1864.
Dumas was a fair
master to us all.
He taught me to read and write.
I was a man servant,
if not a man.
At my work, I studied natural
things, all manner of plants,
birds, I draw now in my book,
wren, willet, egret, loon.
Tending the gardens, I thought
only to study live things,
thought never to know
so much about the dead.
Now I tend Ship Island
graves, mounds like dunes
that shift and disappear.
I record names, send
home simple notes,
not much more than how and
when, an official duty.
I'm told it's best
to spare most detail.
But I know there are things
which must be accounted for.
1865.
These are things which
must be accounted
for, slaughter under the
white flag of surrender,
black massacre at Fort
Pillow, our new name, the Core
D'Afrique, words that take
the native from our claim,
mossbacks and freedmen,
exiles in their own homeland,
the diseased, the maimed, every
lost limb and what remains,
phantom ache, memory
haunting an empty sleeve,
the hog-eaten at Gettysburg,
unmarked in their graves,
all the dead letters unanswered,
untold stories of those
that time will render mute.
Beneath battlefields,
green again,
the dead molder, a scaffolding
of bone we tread upon,
forgetting truth be told.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]